اعمده دخان اشتباكات مسلحه رصاص ودماء
انها سله العرب الغذائيه التي ملئت قنابل
ومتفجرات بدل الطعام والشراب
نحو سته عشر انقلابا عسكريا ومحاوله
انقلاب منذ استقلاله بعثرت خيراته واهدرت
مقدراته انه السودان
نحو 46 مليون مواطن نصفهم فقراء في بلد
فيه اكثر من عشره انهار طبيعيه ومئه وخمسه
وسبعين مليون فدان من الاراضي الصالحه
للزراعه في السودان ما يزيد عن 100 مليون
راس من الماشيه اي اضعاف ما تملكه هولندا
هنا تاسع بلد منتج للذهب على مستوى العالم
وثالث بلد منتج للنفط على مستوى افريقيا
[موسيقى]
وفيما تتواصل الاشتباكات بين الجيش والدعم
السريع تعالت الاصوات شعبيا مطالبه بوقفها
على الفور والوصول الى حلول تلبي طموح
المدنيين بسودان مختلف
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات